Antti male circumcision groups bolstered
by proposals to ban the ritual for boys
in iceland hope to pressure the British
Medical Association to condemn the
practice in Britain roughly four percent
of boys born here are circumcised the
BMA outlines best practice but takes no
position on whether the non-medical
ritual is ethical senior rabbi Zanna
moms have said that a move to ban the
practice contravenes their religious
freedom
I used to unreservedly support this
right but having since researched it and
despite the serious religious taboos
around me saying so I became unable to
justify removing someone else's body
parts without their consent especially
without any medical grounds as a Muslim
who's been circumcised I'm no longer
convinced the religious freedom argument
holds circumcision is imposed as the
parents religious choice on their baby
the boy is given no say as such it is
the exact opposite of religious freedom
now as painful as it is for me and
others to adapt to our cultural identity
I think it's time we raise the age of
consent for circumcision to 16 I
[Music]
actually think circumcision is an act of
faith I think for Jewish people it's a
non-negotiable part of their identity
arguably it's an essential part of
Judaism and I you mentioned Iceland want
to outlaw this it's actually even been
mooted here that would that would mean
that religious Jews or Muslims would
have to leave a country or abandon a
sacred part of their tradition yeah I
know it's been sold as a human right in
Iceland but the for me it's an
aggressive form of secularism and you
know what happens for the rest of
secularism it can become totalitarian
and where the state tells you how to
live what your way of life should be
like how you can bring up your kids this
would subvert a parent's right on what
to do with his earth his or her child so
this is actually the opposite of that
it's not the state telling you how to
live your life is that would they
announce that state no it's not it's the
state asking parents not to force their
views on the child until the child's oh
do not tell yourself
the start of this it's a bit a
non-negotiable no.1 art of the video
then well let me speak to what I know
about which is the mostly my density I'm
not going to speak on behalf of the Jews
and there are sensitivities around that
but what I will say is that actually
having wonder gone the procedure I've
had to face a choice recently as to
whether I repeat the procedure for my
one-year-old child so I looked into this
extensively and felt such a shame such a
stigma and taboos in my own community I
know that I'll be seen as a traitor for
saying what I'm saying now however what
I found is that removing up to 50% of
functioning penal skin that has about
five of the most sensitive parts of the
penis that without medical grounds of
course if there are medical reasons if
there is something that's gonna go wrong
that's different but doing that based
upon my beliefs doing that to a child
without asking them first I don't think
I don't think that I can argue its
religious freedom because actually it's
the child's religious freedom that I
should be thinking but some people say
you're you are safeguarding your child's
health been circumcised or no there's no
circumcised boys are 22 times less
likely to get penile cancer it's
actually as it is note so the spread of
HIV in America three-quarters of all
male babies are looked into where please
trust me that these stats that are
thrown around right like the HIV person
who knows because it's happened to me
and because I was about to do it to my
son I'm saying I took it seriously
enough to look at the evidence and the
counter studies right there I talked
about secularism before turning into
totalitarianism in Iceland where they
where they're debating this there are
something like 250 Jews and 1500 Muslims
what do you think that says why is it so
important in a country that owned that
has been left to me that smacks of total
that's really interesting because I
think ordinarily when it comes to these
sorts of discussions you're not concern
about their feelings and I'm saying that
actually yeah well because the thing is
is since I'm I'm for me and I come from
a culture that circumcised is its boys
and so I am torn over this issue in
terms of whether or not I think it
should be banned in general obviously
you cannot compare it to female
circumcision and my culture does not do
practice FGM but as I am so against FGM
and I'm so against female circumcision
and obviously you don't have the same
medal - I know you don't have the same
medically important all I'm saying is
that maybe actually what we need to get
to is - to ban it have you looked have
you looked at the lighter form of why is
it that you're so insensitive is but yet
you're against hair jobs per se on the
female side of things right how is it
lighter for more - I think you know on
the lighter form you can right so the
lighter form of female circumcision
removes just removing involves just
removing the tip of the skin over the
clitoris the lighter feel now
that's nobody would ever countenance
doing that right and yet yet it's
actually quite comparable to male
circumcision and that's why when I
thought about it I thought I'm being a
hypocrite quick senator me then let's
get courage it's surely the system is
working you can choose to do what you do
with your little be guided by parental
and fatherly wisdom grow up I'm not
gonna speak on the one point that there
is no comparison with females I mean
that is barbaric yeah that is bans that
is illegal and awful yeah indeed here
we've got something that the medical
proof shows that actually there is no
great difference between the two so it's
not something that is harming
the boy indeed there are religious
reasons why it's done which we've
discussed with the Jewish community the
Muslim community there also cultural in
in many African communities in mic that
happens at a much older age there when
they're approaching puberty around 13
years old tends to be the age that they
have to do it it's very painful and they
do it because of cultural reasons you
have religious reasons you have cultural
reasons but in this country we have free
choice as individuals so if an
individual like you your of your Muslim
but you said I don't want to do this for
my child you didn't do it you know but
other people through their religious
beliefs feel they have heard now when
you talk about Karen to control how many
other things to parents control that we
had no this is where I was gonna correct
something right so I didn't I didn't
exercise this is why I think it's being
framed wrong I didn't exercise my
religious freedom to choose not to do it
that's actually not how I think it
should be framed what the choice I made
was to allow my child to have their own
religious freedom to choose for
themselves rather than impose my views
on my child and that's the correct
framing because what we're doing unlike
unlike choosing which school our child
goes to unlike for example dressing our
child in a particular way we're making
an irreversible choice to remove up to
50% of the functioning penile skin when
he's well at no harm yes there's no
illness that results from it but there
is a harm and that harm has been proven
scientifically that we reduce the
sensation around the penis which is the
pleasure that the male enjoys from
sexual intercourse because of a choice
we've made for the child and the child
didn't have a say in it that's why the
system is a weak